hey guys it's inio and today we're doing
a little temperature test with the
samsung s2 ultra that's because spigen
released their cryo armor case and they
say it helps to regulate the phone's
temperature for a cooler phone
experience so
let's test it out
all right let's get this out of the box
[Applause]
let's do that
so the back of the case is smooth enough
so that your phone doesn't get scratched
up and the back is really well detailed
and i like the textures down here the
little crevices in between the hexagons
are meant to dissipate heat so we'll see
how this works out so first things first
we need to
take this phone
and do a temperature check just to see
where it stands as a control
it's about 27.8 let's check the back
i'd say yeah on average it's like 28
degrees
about 28 degrees yeah so it's pretty
chill on its own okay so the average
temperature without the case is about 28
degrees celsius so let's just hop into a
game of apex and see how it turns out
after the game all right let's run
through the settings real quick
yeah let's see display settings okay
ultra hd we're gonna go extreme
and ultra frame rate
and they've all taken effect so let's
just hop into a game
countdown
[Applause]
okay so low temperature check mid game
so far it's about 35.3 by the back
we are at
34.85.435.9
yeah i'd say to say it's about like 36
degrees celsius about 36.5
so let's just keep playing for a full
game and see where we get
saved by the train now
[Applause]
oh everyone okay cool
okay let's see how this fares at the end
[Applause]
hitting about oh 40 degrees 38 degrees
37.4 around 40 degrees down here
i'm guessing this where the chip's at
yeah
so as you can see it's pretty hot in the
back and it is
very warm so the phone is pretty warm at
the back and the front so let's let it
cool down to the base temperature of 20
degrees celsius and we'll come back and
try out the
spigen cryo armor but before that here's
a message from our sponsor here at geek
culture we love our keyboards especially
with the all new logitech mx keys mini
an elegant and functional keyboard its
ultra responsive rounded keycaps are
super stable and quiet for more
productivity there are buttons to enable
dictation microphone audio control and
emojis the backlit keys illuminate when
you get close and matches the lighting
of the environment you're in it lasts up
to 10 days on a full charge or 5 months
with the backlights turned off to find
out more about the logitech mx keys mini
and their latest range of products head
over to logitech.com okay and we're back
so let's just see what temperature we
have right now
it's about 23 degrees 25 oh
oh 24 degrees okay so that's as cool as
it's gonna get
so
with that out of the way let's put on
the cryo ammo
a little nice little
nice
yeah it looks really good it feels
really good in the hand as well
so let's see how this pans out at the
end of a round of apex
but yeah i have to say that you know
having this cover around it right makes
it very easy to grip on to the s2
compared to without the cover
oh people beyond deep around us
go down reloading
[Music]
reloading
there we go
okay so after that engagement let's just
check how it's doing on the inside
all right
it's not as warm
still okay about 32.3 31.
i think that's a low improvement from
just now
it's not that bad
let's put it back inside
nope nope
[Applause]
reloading
open
[Applause]
beginning ring countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's the game
okay so let's check out the back
still about 36 around here
and
39.9 on here
i think that's where the chip said like
i said just now but
all in all it doesn't feel as warm as it
was just now let's just check the front
real quick
yeah
it's not as hot as it was just now
to be honest
so yeah i i guess we can safely say that
the spigen cry armor does help a little
bit when it comes to dissipating heat
from your phone and honestly playing
with this feels so much better than
playing it without the cover so good job
spigen
final thoughts on the cry armor this
thing is a pretty good gaming case not
only do you have a firm grip on the
phone it feels comfortable in your hands
and it does help a little bit with the
heat dissipation as you've seen
throughout the video so if you guys have
any questions about the case let me know
in the comment section down below don't
forget to follow us on all of our
socials like this video and subscribe to
us it helps us out a lot this is ineo
and i'll chat to you guys in the next
one
[Music]
oh